[Music]
a longtime
friend of the campus a friend
of this cosmologist a friend of physics
and that is none other than dr
eric weinstein who today is joining us
uh from an undisclosed location but uh
maybe we'll get into that
uh we have already 114 people watching
with many thumbs up
one thumbs down for my mother mom how
could you do that
that's wrong mom don't do that she's
just to me she says not to you
uh eric how are you doing today i'm work
brian good to be with you
it's great to be with you it's been four
months exactly or three months exactly
since we last conversed
via this medium when we had on our
mutual friends uh
max tegmark and garrett lisey and that
was of course very enjoyable
uh for me to go over this go over some
of the
long-standing questions i've been having
in this exploration of the multiverse of
brilliant minds that grace me with their
presence
on the into the impossible podcast i
have been
not a stranger to the work that you've
been working on
some say it is the work of a lifetime
some say it is revolutionary and could
have
tremendous implications some have
questions about it
because of its far-reaching implications
and we're talking about
uh universal theories of everything
perhaps a new one
created by today's guest eric weinstein
uh and that goes by the moniker
geometric unity
and i've been fascinated with this ever
since i heard about it probably 10 years
ago almost 10 years ago now
uh and today i thought it'd be fun to
get eric on the show
as he has uh promised to to at least
be uh be interested in coming on to
discuss
recent developments that uh that the
listenership of this fine podcast
would be interested to know and as you
know eric we go deep so first of all i
want to say
uh i want to say thank you and i want to
ask you
what is new in the theories of
everything space
in particular we're hearing a lot of
talk nowadays from people like michio
kaku who will be a guest on my podcast
next week
about uh about the god equation and my
first question to you uh
which is always of interest to me
personally is
why does a theory of physics have
anything to say about god or any
relevance to god whatsoever before we
get into the nitty gritty details
well there are two things i think that
are up which are
um one is man's rigorous attempt to
understand his circumstance
necessarily um intersects you with god
which is a traditional explanation for
why is everything here
and the other is that god sells and
part of the problem is if you name
something the really important particle
that we just discovered
that's not going to sell as many books
as the god particle
and so we want to know god's thoughts we
want god particles
and then we back away from them we claim
no no i didn't mean god particle i meant
god damn particle
and this is a game that we play with the
public where we try to amp the public
up and get them hot and bothered and
once they're
sufficiently in a lather we try to
educate them about the real nature of
the universe
so think about it from a computer
perspective is syntactic sugar we're
pouring god all over something
hoping that people will swallow them and
of course i'm uh i'm holding up on the
screen right now in my screen
i'm sharing a highlighted section from
that great work of literature
known as a brief history of time and
this was one of the books that got me
interested in cosmology and astronomy by
the late great stephen hawking who
passed away
uh exactly uh three years ago on
einstein's birthday
on pi day at least here in the united
states uh
the 14th of march by the way he
do you know what other famous figure he
shares his demise date with eric
i don't a a jewish intellectual by the
name of
karl marx so uh carl had an
impact on universal capitalism and uh
einstein uh of course was born that day
and hawking
died that day and in the final paragraph
of the book he says
if we can discover if we can all
have part in a final theory then we
shall all philosophers
scientists and just ordinary people be
able to take part in the discussion of
the question
of why is it that we in the universe
exist
if we find the answer to that it would
be the ultimate triumph of human reason
for then we would know the mind of god
and as you said these things sell it was
rumored that he said
every equation cuts your audience
readership in half
every mention of god doubles it so at
some level there's conservation here
but i was always taught
sorry i was always taught where physics
is not
for why questions and yet there it is
he's bringing up why questions
uh what do you make of that is can
physics provide the why
i feel like when you are talking in
these terms you
are reasonably confident that the person
is not trying to
read the mind of god because one
wouldn't trifle with god in such a way
i believe that in some sense if you
really worry that the telephone is
connected
you'd probably speak about this
differently you might you might be
humorous you might
i don't know i there's something about
the fact that we talk in this way
and it feels to me like
um when moses uh
is uh seeing a bush that is not consumed
by flame but appears to be in flame
he knows pretty well that you should be
a little careful
and i just i don't understand the
impulse to constantly
godify everything and certainly i'll
have on michio kaku
next week on the into the impossible
podcast and i hope uh maybe we'll get a
cameo by
uh by from you but um but in his
book he writes something very
provocative and he says at the end of
his book
he quotes those lines from stephen
hawking which is kind of like this
infinite regress
which i um which i you know kind of
strains credulity
uh so to speak but he says at one point
he says
um uh he says it's not fair
to test string theory to ask to test
string theory experimentally
because we don't know its final
principles but the same
i claim could have been said about
quantum mechanics do we know the final
principles of
quantum mechanics does that immunize it
from experimental test
again these are the same questions over
and over again there's something very
wrong about the simplistic nature of the
scientific method
and the relationship between experiment
and theory and instance and idea
and we're effectively playing through
the exact same
set of problems where we hold up one
theory to some sort
of experimental threshold we give a pass
to another theory
and we're all the time pretending that
we're not actually
doing what we're really doing which is
observing who believes in what theory
one of the reasons string theory got
such
a boost is that the brilliance of the
initial um
volunteers in for the first string
revolution around 1984
were so good that we were inclined to
give them a huge
pass at least at first and
then we have this differential
application where
the string theorists become
paradoxically the most
persnickety about what is a prediction
because
they don't want to give up the fact that
they aren't really making predictions
and so if you for example predict
internal quantum numbers of the next
particles to be found but you don't come
up with an energy threshold and you
don't say what will invalidate your
theory they get angry
because in fact what we've done is we've
given them a
an asymmetric relationship with the
scientific method through special
pleading
so we have a really unfortunate
situation which is that we have highly
simplistic
prepariance highly simplistic devotees
of the scientific method
and i really think that people need to
go back to dirac's 1963 scientific
american article
to understand that the real issue is
very weird and we haven't really talked
about it there were three big
names in the 20th century in my mind who
contributed something like physical law
and uh leaving dr mills
out of it for the moment i would say
that einstein de rock and yang
tower not necessarily that they were the
best physicists
although i think i could make a pretty
good claim
in all three cases but that physical law
is different than the consequences of
physical law
and the people who seem to do well with
physical law employ mechanisms that
would drive
sabine hossenfelder to distraction they
talk a lot about beauty and elegance and
simplicity
and what dirac said was that don't
force people who come up with new
physical laws
to play the game of agreement with
experiment because the
instance of an idea can easily be off
and not agree
with experiment and
then you have a problem whereby you're
pushing people
initially the instant you open your
mouth say what it is
that would invalidate your theory so
we'll know that you're wrong if you're
wrong
um and i i don't know who this is
intended to fool
it's completely irresponsible and what
it is
is an attempt to constantly take anyone
who would come
forward with an idea and put them
instantaneously on the defensive
and i think that the right thing to do
is to sit people down and say
you're supposed to be adults and if we
look at our history
everybody who's proposed new physical
law
and gotten it right had errors einstein
didn't get the divergence free part
he was vague before that with with
grossman
famously derock's theory of quantum
electrodynamics took almost 20 years
before the renormalization
revolution um supplied the ability to
compute with it we had a confusion
between the bare and the dressed mass
and famously the degeneracy in in
well between the electron and the proton
we had two particles we claimed
that dirac claimed to be anti-particles
because he was too timid to suggest
a positron and an antiproton
which has
the mass asymmetry uh yang's
theory uh if left massless wouldn't come
up with the right rates for
for beta decay if you didn't impart mass
to the w and z
to the intermediate vector boson so i
think that you have a situation by which
um new ideas are always not
properly instantiated and the community
that is constantly trying to make sure
that
i think that the idea is that people are
foolish enough to play this game
with the most aggressive members of the
community because the the
the implication is if you won't come up
with a testable prediction that
invalidates your theory
you're anti-scientific and we have no
time for this and so people
like you know the su-5 theory they
immediately said okay well it predicts
proton decay
well grand unification is a larger idea
and some
versions and instantiations do predict
proton decay and some do not
so you know what are you going to say
about that i think that
the the problem is is that we're not in
an adult phase where we faced up to the
fact
that we have almost 50 years of
stagnation
and what you're seeing with this
proliferation of
new claimants to have fundamental
theories
is in part that string theory has
finally weakened itself
and the aging of the particular um
cohort which is baby boomers who are the
string theory proponents
they've gotten weak enough that
effectively other people
feel emboldened and i think you know
stephen wolfram said this recently that
in a previous era he would have expected
to have been attacked
but we've been waiting around for so
long that perhaps
the political economy of unification and
wild ideas
has changed someone and uh before we get
off the subject of the why
questions um i do like uh
a framework that i've heard you and
almost no one
besides you portray laws of fundamental
physics and that's using the
good old-fashioned mechanism we were all
taught in high school
journalism uh the 5w approach
and i wonder if we could start there
with
why that is a good deconstructivist
approach
to ascertaining the realm of validity of
a physical law of a purported
new theory a theory of everything which
i dislike that moniker as you know
but nevertheless can you talk about that
framework and how
uh for our up-and-coming but bright uh
listeners of which there are many
currently watching right now how you
approach that using the 5ws
why that's so important and then maybe
that will segue into a description of
the actual physical instantiation of
that framework
i will point out that how has the w on
the end
um yeah i i think that
um
i usually do it as uh
as who where and when who and what how
and why
um and
let's just say first of all what we
generally speaking mean
by uh a theory what we're usually
talking about
is a
way in which waves can propagate
and interact in various media
right the theories of the world are
theories of
wave waves in interaction waves imply
media so the where and when
is sort of a particular kind of a
substrate usually which
einstein uh imbued with the name space
time where being space when being time
the who and the what i take to be
fractional spin and integral spin
particles
every particle that we know of that's
fundamental is one or the other
[Music]
so let's say that the what
is the um the fermionic fractional spin
particles and the who
is the integral spin generally speaking
force particles non-gravitational
um but then we also have to throw in
the higgs and the metric for zero spin
zero and spin two
and then there's the how and the y which
would be
the uh
the how would be the equations of motion
and the y
would be the lagrangian that generates
the equations
and so in some sense it's not surprising
then that
a theory has to conform to the basic
idea of when you're trying to tell
somebody something these are the
questions that we
we want to ask and it's a surprisingly
tight mapping
i just find that people can better
remember that
because very often what we've done is
we've we've taught people
to focus on the wrong things when we
talk about
fundamental physics whether they're
overly focused on entanglement
they're very focused on quantum
measurement they have no idea about
bundles they don't have ideas about
symmetry groups or why symmetry groups
are important
and so for some reason when people learn
about theories of everything they're
very animated but they're very animated
as to what
on the grounds of what has sold books
recently
that's right we have no shortage of
multi-verses double slit
experiments spooky action at a distance
and other invocations
of this gentleman i point out that
einstein is weinstein
with a w okay you uh
you have a fascination with w's
obviously uh
so uh i want to go starting with
einstein
uh to something that i know is very
influential to you
and it's sort of a provocative question
that has inspired you apparently and
that was a question
uh a stylized question posed to ernst
strauss by albert einstein regarding the
amount of freedom
present in our field theoretic universe
what is that question
well the question is how much freedom
is there and what we take to be the
standard model
and that's our i'm using a term of art
accidentally
how much freedom is there
to construct the universe and is this
one of many that could have been
constructed or is it effectively unique
are we talking about
the god concept if you will
as a design constraint where things are
the way they are because they could not
be otherwise
and i think that you know this is a very
it's a very interesting question because
in some sense i don't know that he meant
it this way but i took it to be a
research
program
and in terms of it uh providing this
direction for you
is the question itself the research
direction or is the
overarching theme of of sort of freedom
flexibility within physical laws the
the programmatic uh you know kind of
marching orders that you took
unto yourself it's an interesting
question i mean i think that
what i don't understand is that people
talk about theories of everything
casually as if a theory of everything is
sort of
it may not be a very artful term it's
sort of theories of all the rules not
what can be played
once one knows all the rules
i guess what i take it to mean
is that we have a problem of even
conceiving
of what a non-effective theory would be
what what is an ultimate theory
i mean i think that you know in large
measure i see
two kind of canonical versions one of
them i would sort of associate with
garrett lisi's
e8 idea although i don't believe that
that works
you start with something incredibly rich
that exists by necessity like a large
exceptional lead group or
maybe a large finite group or something
that is somehow distinguished
and then you attempt to milk it for
peculiarities that can be identified
with our world and that's how you get
the richness of our world
[Music]
whether or not you believe in garrett's
theory i do think it's emblematic of an
approach
another approach is sort of closer to
embryology
where you start with something that is
deceptively simple like a
single fertilized egg
and then you ask does that um
attempt in some sense to bootstrap
itself into the totality of existence
and that's much closer to what i ended
up doing i mean i considered carrots e8
thing before i ever met garrett um
because e8 is
spinorial it's chiral it has lots of
stylized things that
seem to fit our world but i couldn't
figure out how to really make it into a
theory and then
i went the other direction i think it's
pointless to ask why is there something
rather than nothing
unless i'm mistaken i think that the
point of
a fundamental theory is to get the
scientists
to accept the initial input is so
uninteresting to go beyond
that they put down their pens and the
theologians and philosophers take over
and you imagine that the initial input
to the universe
is just four dimensions for example
um i don't think that many scientists
would be motivated to say
why are there four dimensions at a
scientific level
because that sort of begs the
it's not enough of a clue for
anything to proceed scientifically i
mean maybe all
versions of multiple dimensions maybe
there's 17 dimensions too
um so i think that in large measure
the gambit that i'm trying to follow as
misguided as it sounds
is is four dimensions
on its own in the form of a manifold
with a few extra mild
conditions like you know a single unique
spin structure something like that
uh orientable is a nice four-dimensional
manifold sufficient
to start the universe from
effectively no other major assumptions
and that's that's how crazy this is
so when you say this we're talking about
geometric unity a reminder we're talking
to eric weinstein dr eric weinstein
proprietor of the portal podcast and you
can find his youtube channel at
nobani88 which is a cryptic reference to
uh the year i had my first kiss uh i
don't know why it's called that but it
should be the portal we'll get that
fixed eric in the meantime could you
tilt your
webcam down just a tiny bit so your head
is not at the bottom of the
of the frame that would make it yes very
good very nice
um so what is fundamental i've had these
conversations uh just recently on my
podcast with dr steven meyer
who you know is a proponent of the
intelligent design hypothesis
i'm not going to get into that i am a
critic of that and we are
yet good friends uh but you know he
makes the case then things like the
guth the lincoln uh conjecture or in
the lawrence krauss universe from
nothing we always start
with the laws of nature and and
instantiation thereof
so too with debates i've had with sean
carroll a friend of mine and a greatly
respected
mentor in the field that god could have
chosen to start the universe with an
empty hilbert space is his conjecture
and therefore
there's a simpler universe than the one
we inhabit we're not going to talk about
sean necessarily we're not going to talk
about stephen meyer but i want to talk
about
what is the fundamental element the
yelm the thing from which emerges space
time
or is the space time or observers if we
can go there now
is that truly fundamental or is it
emergent
which what what comes first the
observers or the observer
well first of all i mean let me just say
a few words
um what we're talking about
is crazy i think it's really important
to just own up to the fact that for
people who want sober physics
this is probably not the channel for you
today
now no i mean i i take this stuff very
seriously because i don't like the
bullshitty aspect and we're using april
1st
as a contrivance because i think that
many people
are induced to self-inhibit because
particular members of the community are
incredibly aggressive
in making it extremely expensive to
explore ideas
and i'd like to think that living
outside the community i could start a
tradition
to make it at least inexpensive one day
a year
to throw the middle finger to those
people
who like to play simon says games or
reputational destruction games
now a purge a purge for physics
well there should be many more such days
and i'd love to get there but let's at
least start with
one a year so this is my second year
round
trying to hit this look i believe at
some level
that the initial ingredient
may just be a four-dimensional manifold
and then things emerge from that
a four-dimensional manifold with a
little bit of extra structure
but that's that's why this is crazy
so it starts from very modest uh modest
inputs and from
from such modest inputs comes a rather
extravagant universe
and let's talk about the inputs and i
don't know how closely you want to
follow
if you want to share screens or anything
like that we're free to do that
what are the inputs there are the
players the matter players there are the
the gauge bosons there are um new
predictions there are new
uh new concepts that geometric unity
has provided and so the question
uh i guess first of all is uh how close
do we want to
follow this uh prescription of
uh what's what is what has been
portrayed in the past
and or do we want to talk about what is
new in the preceding
year since the last episode of april
uh fool's purge podcasting began with
the portal special episode
well you know it's very interesting um
to consider that
we've had a year where
um there's been a fair amount of
interest in it
and let's be honest very little of the
interest has been
uh particularly detailed
um i would have thought that
um maybe what i said was understandable
and then oddly a paper
purporting to critique the theory
managed to demonstrate that they had
understood fairly well
what i had said and that it was
understandable
unfortunately there was one named author
and a imaginary friend and i don't
respond
well to people posing beyond
behind pseudonyms but part of that was
constructive
and um
you know i'm attempting to share
a bit of screen now okay
uh here i'll add that
okay so now it's false you've got the
full screen on the paper
okay so effectively what i'm asking is
can a manifold x4
produce the baroque structure of the
standard model now
and gravity and if you think back to the
famous mug popular in the
cern gift shop there really isn't
that much going on in the standard model
if you group terms
in particular ways but there's a lot of
weirdness why
why the lorentz group why su 3 cross su
2 cross u1 for the
internal symmetries generating the
forces y3 families
and i i thought that's
something that many younger viewers uh
may not be aware of
is that things really changed
around 1983-84
and if you think about the original
anomaly
cancellation of green and schwartz in
1984 i believe
you could ask what was physics like
right before that moment
and i think it's absolutely shocking
because we don't realize the extent to
which the string theorists really
redefined
what the major problems in physics were
i think most people in the post-string
era
somehow believe that the major issue is
quantum gravity
and i don't really i i just find it
astounding because that's really what
the string theorists were selling
so this is from murray gelman's address
to the second shelter island conference
where they were trying to recapture
the magic from ram's head in after the
world war
ii when the young physicists were
invited
to uh you know feeling that they had
done well on the
engineering project that was the
manhattan project
they were buoyed in their confidence
and you know years later in 1983 murray
galman says well what are the big
problems as usual solving the problems
of one era has shown up
the critical questions for the next the
first ones that come to mind looking at
the standard theory of today are and
then
i think this is absolutely shocking and
it indicates the extent to which
the current generation has really given
up on doing what we would typically have
called
physics um relegating the things that
are relevant to the physical universe
that we
see usually to the realm of particle
phenomenology
um okay so what are his big questions
why this particular structure for the
families in particular why flavor chiral
with left and right handed particles
being treated differently by the weak
force
rather than say vector like which left
and right transformable into being
treated the same
next why three families that generalizes
robbie's famous question who ordered
that as if
the universe was a jewish deli uh
comment on the muon
um how many sets of higgs bosons are
there we talk about the higgs boson
but maybe there are multiple sets and
there are multiple different scales at
which symmetry is broken and mass is
imparted
through soft mass mechanisms lastly why
su-3 cross su-2 cross u1 remember su 3
is the color force for the strong force
but su 2 here
is a weak isospin which has not yet
become the w and z's and this u1 is weak
hypercharged which has not yet become
electromagnetism
through symmetry breaking and
in some sense i i just feel sort of sad
that we don't think of these as
questions because we know not to ask
them and somehow we got
convinced that uh we were being called
to quantize gravity not necessarily if
if gravity is geometric um you could
just as easily have said should we be
geometrizing the quantum and if we
geometrize the quantum
you would notice that this era would
have been triumphant because
that's really what happened we didn't do
a lot of physics
but we really did put the framework of
physics that is quantum field theory
quantum measurement
classical field theory all in very
geometric
frameworks in fact i would say that
there were three really big revolutions
although we don't talk in these terms
one was the discovery by
simons and yang of the woo yang
dictionary
blanking on wu's name which is singer
was also instrumental
in taking to oxford then there's the
geometric quantization revolution where
the quantum was understood to be
intrinsically geometric
because the heisenberg uncertainty
relations should emerge from the
curvature tensor of a pre-quantum line
bundle with the sections being
the states of a vector space once
polarization is taken into account
and then lastly the geometric
quantum field theory revolution in which
we came to understand the quantum field
theory really isn't about the physical
world that
it gets applied in one particular set of
inputs to the physical world but it's
actually a
mature mathematical enhancement of
boardism theory from topology
so those three major revolutions all
went exactly counter to quantize gravity
they said let's geometrize the quantum
instead and so they did
and uh did how successful should we
regard this uh the the resulting
byproduct or lack thereof progress lack
thereof and the intervening
this is very unpleasant to have to say
this but i think that
we are talking about a great era with
heroes
um the top hero among them
uh is undoubtedly ed whitton um
but i do believe that yang and simons
um i think yang and simon's discovery of
erasmanian bundle theory
uh which has a precursor um
and i'm blanking on the gentleman's name
all the self-published books
from uh
[Music]
from the 60s it'll come to me but
there was a man in boston who probably
got there a little bit earlier
and then i would say that you know you
have accidental physicists dan quillin
for example
did a huge amount to
talk about you know connections on uh
determinant bundles
and the like which come out of um
various quantization
procedures particularly with bears and
integration of fermion sectors
so i i think that a lot of things got
done to shore
up what we do to mature input into a
quantum theory
it just it wasn't physics per se it was
sort of the mathematics of physics
and i think that that was very
frustrating which is
you know it's sort of to physicists it's
yeoman's work they wanted to go to
stockholm
uh and they ended up you know winning
the first
fields medal won by a physicist and i
think
it's weird it's it's like what is your
time your time is whatever it is
that can be done and they thought their
time was to quantize gravity well guess
again
nature said we have something incredibly
important so i feel like
i'm trying to rescue their legacy they
want to go down as
string theorists for the most part and
they want to say that string theory was
the more successful
most successful of any claimant even
though it wasn't very successful
but yes i feel like we can say that it's
not very successful
because they gave us the terms in which
we should evaluate it
you know i remember being told give us
10 years we'll have the whole thing
cleaned up don't worry your pretty
little head will be fine
um you know or we have a finite number
of theories to check
and then lo and behold there's a
continuum or why is it called string
theory when there are brains involved
and
it was because if you ask once upon a
time they say well you know it's not
like mathematicians didn't think about
higher dimensional objects beyond
strings
um there was an explanation for why
there were no brains
and you know
that yeah string theory has failed in
its own
terms now is it solvable are there
pivots beyond yeah sure i
i'm not saying that they didn't stumble
on a tremendous amount of structure
maybe that structure ultimately carries
the day
but i do think that the idea that
they're entitled to this many pivots
uh without having to become
self-reflective
is preposterous and i think many people
feel that way and they just know that
they might pay
for such a statement with their career
and since i've
prepaid it falls to people like me and
to you
perhaps to say
look the string theorists weren't able
to confront their failure
when we talk about these things in
rather you know some say grandiose terms
uh i think sometimes it uh we do lose
sight
i really don't want to use the word
grandiose like are we going to talk
about grandiose unified theory
let's be honest about it physics is the
most honest
way to ask the most grand questions
in the universe absolutely physics is
graduates
then we've got real problems then grand
doesn't exist and if grand doesn't exist
then grandiose doesn't exist so my
feeling is no
this is the actual grand quest and we're
not going to back off it and
be [ __ ] about it this is not
grandiose this is the real deal i was
thinking of my speaking of myself
uh being a self and aggrandizement
of of seeking these ultimate questions
but we do and i was going to give
physics a a good deal of credit because
we do ask these ultimate questions
and yet of course a day-to-day basis i
remember you know wanting to help you
out as a
little role i could play in the
exposition of this uh magnificent
opus that you're working on and saying
you know like eric this is great
but i got a bunch of kids i got to go
pick up and you said well maybe that's
why we'll never get off the planet you
know because guys
and girls everybody has to pick up dry
cleaning every time you got to pick up
your dry cleaning
but uh but we when we lose sight of it i
find with my
colleagues and i'll speak you know
because i doubt many of them are
listening
i really don't feel like they're that
curious intellectually i think it is a
job i think their their job is the dry
cleaning
and i can sort of prove that in some
ways because i often hear them say
things like
well eric is a showman you know he's a
podcaster he's a
he's a host you know and he's had
training and he's very smooth and
and he can speak well and i say well do
you think he do you think he emerged
from the womb like that and and by the
way
you do mr or mrs professor doctor doctor
uh professor you got a lot of training
in quantum field theory
and uh string theory yourself that was
presumably a challenge for you you
didn't emerge
womb-like you know from the caverns of
the womb knowing quantum fielders so you
had to work at that so it's all about
prioritization
why do you think physicists aren't more
troubled by the lack of progress that
our mutual friend sabina has pointed out
uh in in the last 50 years at least in
fundamental physics
my colleagues will rightfully point out
tremendous advances
in cosmological theory in condensed
matter theory etc
but why isn't that more troubling i
think the answer is we're not that
curious you you have an
over you have a vision of us that's
maybe uh
more um more more refined than i think
we deserve and that's because you're not
a professional physicist
look um you know i feel very similar
about my feelings about physics as an
outsider to the way i view the uk
when i go to the uk very often they they
seem to be defeated
um because they lost their empire which
they should never have had in the first
place
but you know my feeling is if you really
look at the uk it's an amazing place
and any outsider should be able to see
that um
i i guess what i what i think about here
is that any outsider who really takes
physics seriously should be able to see
that this is our premier
community intellectually it is the most
accomplished of intellectual communities
and it's also very badly behaved and
it's fallen on hard times
and you know it's like seeing a grand
family that's forgotten itself because
it has to constantly submit to the
archive and you know we now have the
snarkive as you know
and the snarkive was filled with papers
that are indistinguishable
as a turing test from archived papers
i think i look for like i don't know the
gelman nishijima formula on hep
th and i realized that people really
weren't doing physics
you know there's certain things that you
would have to do if you were going to do
physics
and i don't mean to say that no physics
is going on but my god
it's really people that just don't
believe anymore
i don't think i think that when you when
you're talking about almost 50 years of
a particular kind of failure in
fundamental physics
where theories and predictions
effectively become
accepted as being the likely
explanations for the universe
we're getting to the point where
everybody who's contributed to the
standard model after this year will be
over seven
and what do you say to the younger
people who say they they can't
understand it they can't
comprehend geometric unity our friend
sabina
she can't understand it it's is it too
complex for her
no there's a bunch of different games
one
game is the i can't understand all this
fancy pants stuff
another game is be hyper specific so we
can invalidate you
another you know there's another game
which is uh
well we know that you don't know quantum
field theory really well so
what energy level do these things kick
in at you know and
i find all of this incredibly
dispiriting and exhausting because it's
also transparent
i can we can say what geometric unity
actually is
we can draw pictures people can get it
and in fact
i was talking to my good buddy joe rogan
earlier today
and a particular group of
people who listened to my podcast
put up a site for joe called
um pull that up jamie
uh dot com and that up if you wanted
you want to navigate to pull that up
jamie.com
in part this is below sabina's level
um but i'm happy to you know if you if
you got her on the horn she could
she could understand what's being said
yeah i have no doubt about that um the
question is
you know when we talk in the language uh
bundles of fibers et cetera
uh at what level do people kind of lose
lose the physics for the geometry for
the pure
mathematical and i think um but let's
walk
walk the first step and then let's watch
people who are technically capable
claim that they can't follow what's
going on because i don't think it's true
so um you have xn
for manifold and n dimensions make it
orientable with a particular orientation
make it have a unique spin structure
whatever
you need to do to set it up as a decent
manifold
replace that manifold momentarily
by the bundle of
all metric tensors
point wise on the same space
in that way space-time would be a
particular section of that bundle
let's see if i can find a
so the first thing is that the observers
replaces space-time
and again you're not trying to
kill off einstein you're trying to
recover einstein from a different
structure
so i'm looking
[Music]
okay so he right here
i've got a four dimensional manifold
imagine that i'm interested in looking
at the bundle of all point wise metrics
which is going to be if the base space
is four dimensional
make four equal to n it will be a
dimension
n squared plus 3n divided by 2.
so 4 squared is 16
plus 3n 3 times 4 is 12.
so 16 plus 12 is 28 divided by
2 is 14. if you have a 1 comma 3 metric
downstairs i believe that you are
naturally courting a 7 7 or 6 or 9
5 metric upstairs
and that is the first step
in gu which is that you replace a single
space with one particular metric
by a pair of spaces a total space and a
base space of a fiber bundle
this is in the strong form of gu
and physics mostly happens upstairs on
the bundle of
all metrics not downstairs
on the particular space that got you
started
here u4 is an open set in x4
okay so effectively what are we saying
we're saying
that physics is going to dance
on not only the space of four
coordinates typically x
y z and t or thinking in a coordinate
independent fashion
simply four parameters it's also going
to dance on the space of rulers and
protractors
at every given point
and so that that structure uh
is the beginning of gu and then you can
recover einstein
space time by simply saying
that if i have a section of that bundle
that's a space time metric
so uh when you say in the simplest form
or in the reduced form
of g what do you mean
well i gave three forms of gu
one form is the trivial form
in which
you have the second space y
the same as the first space x that means
that you can easily recover everything
einstein did
in as a form of geometric unity by
trivially making the observers
irrelevant
you're just repeating the same space
twice and you've got one map between
them called the identity
and now you're back in your old world so
without loss of generality
um you cover that and another one is a
completely general world
uh which i think uh whether we call it
here
um
well i called the middle one the
einsteinian one where you actually make
the second space
y the the space of of metrics
um and that's the one that i think is
the most interesting but i don't want to
box myself
in because i don't want to play these
games of simon's you said this
you see me completely um
you know i i can play the lawyerly game
as well as anyone if that's what we're
really trying to do i thought we were
trying to do physics
right the the thing that i'm trying to
get at here
is that um
i believe you and i are somehow having a
pullback of a 14 dimensional
conversation right now
my guess is is that there is a space
with a seven comma seven metric
probably more likely than a nine comma
five metric
on fourteen dimensions where
not only are um
the waves that are relevant going over
the original
coordinates x1 through x4
they're also going through four ruler
coordinates
uh on the tangent bundle of the original
x coordinates
so there are four rulers to measure the
four directions
and then there are also going to be six
protractors because if you name the
directions john paul george and ringo
you'd have
john with paul john with george john
with ringo paul with george paul with
ringo
george with ringo right and so those six
protractors um are actually degrees of
freedom
for the fields and the fields live on
that space
and then the question is why do we
perceive
four dimensions and complicated fields
the answer is pullbacks
when you have a metric you have a map
from the base space
into the total space so einstein
we don't think of it this way is
embedding
a lifeless space which is with that form
x4 into a 14 dimensional space before
geometric unity ever even got
on the scene and giving him the ability
to pull back
information which he may say is only
happening on that tiny little slice
that little filament that is the four
dimensional manifold swimming in a 10 in
a 14 dimensional world with a 10
dimensional normal bundle
but why not imagine that actually the
fields are actually
spread out over all 14 dimensions and
then all you're seeing is pullback
information
downstairs now the metric is doing
something new that wasn't doing before
it's pulling back data
that is natural to y14 as
if it was natural uh
on x but i call this invasive fields
versus native fields
just because some species are invasive
and some species are endemic or native
the interesting thing about the bundle
of all spinners sorry the bundle of all
metrics
is that it almost has a metric on it i
don't know if i've ever heard anyone
mention this
the space repeat that the space of all
metrics has
almost has a metric on it yeah nearly
actually in other words well
assume that you haven't chosen a metric
on x4
what you have then is you have a 10
dimensional subspace along the fibers
which we can call the vertical
space and
that 10 dimensional space at every point
upstairs
every point is in fact a metric
downstairs
by construction right so that means that
it imparts
a metric on 10 dimensional
vectors along the fibers now those are
symmetric
two tensors effectively because it's a
space of metrics
you have this really interesting space
here um
call that v well that v
has a frobenius metric based on the
particular metric
at which you are looking at the tangent
space which is got a 10 dimensional
subspace picked out
if you map that 10 dimensional subspace
into the 14 dimensional
tangent space
of of the manifold y14
you can take a quotient and call that h
and that h will also have a metric
because it's isomorphic to the dual of
the pullback of the cotangent bundle
downstairs and the cotangent bundle
has a metric because at that point that
you picked in y14 is itself a metric
downstairs
so now you've got a metric on v you've
got a metric on
h star and you just don't know how h
star becomes the complement to v
and t that's the only piece of data
you're missing for a metric so you've
got a foreign metric you've got a 10
metric the 10
metric is sitting inside of the tangent
though the 4 metric is naturally sitting
inside of the cotangent bundle
they're weirdly complementary you've got
a metric on the nose but for one piece
of data which we call a connection
so up to a connection
the manifold y14 has a metric on it
without ever having chosen the metric
because it's made out of metric data
now spinners have a really interesting
property
which i would call an exponential
property
and that is the spinner of a direct sum
is the tensor product of the spinners on
the sun ants
that's not sure any spin or is that true
for any spin or just half integer
well that's true for any no it's it's
true for the spin representation it's
not true
generically for any representation i see
but it allows you to build the spinners
on what should be the total space
because now you've got a four
dimensional
um so i think it's here at
3.12 if the spinners of a sum
are the tensor products of the spinners
on the summons
and i create a new bundle which is the
10 dimensional vertical bundle inside
the tangent bundle
direct sum the four dimensional bundle
inside the cotangent bundle
then the spinners on that thing which is
isomorphic and in fact semi-canonically
isomorphic to both the tangent bundle
and the cotangent muscle being chimeric
um it's isomorphic but it's not
canonically it's not fully canonically
it's only semi-canonical
so spinners on that will be identifiable
with the spinners on
y as soon as you have a connection
that completes this and makes it fully
canonically isomorphic
so take home message there is a spin
bundle
up on the bundle of all metrics which is
nearly the spinners on the tangent
bundle that exists without making a
metric choice and if you're really
serious about quantum gravity
you should be very freaked out about the
idea that once you quantize the metric
you've got a whole lot of pain
because the electron and the
hadron bundles and the you know all the
spin one half matter
the medium in which these uh particles
are disturbances or excitations
doesn't really exist in the absence of a
metric choice
if you allow the metric to become
quantum and allow it to blink out
the spin 1 spin 0 and spin 2 particles
may be indeterminate between
observations but the bundle
itself the medium is indeterminate
between fermionic
between observations of the metric for
fermions
so now you're in a really different
conceptual world
everybody should want to free fermion
bundles
from dependence on the metric if they're
serious about letting the metric blink
out in some supposed quantum gravity
regime let me ask you about that for a
second
um so it seems like this is a huge you
know
huge if true i always like to say uh
well we say that but i don't know
whether i just like missed that one hell
of a meeting i just don't understand
why everybody isn't worried about it so
this is huge right this is what you're
saying is that you can get spinners
if i ever made a boneheaded mistake well
this is where
i'm going to i don't i don't think you
have but i'm just a simple experimental
cosmologist okay
i traffic in nuts and bolts of
cosmological
experiments telescopes as you know
detectors and fields
uh i am out of my depth in many cases
but this struck me like a freaking
thunderbolt that you are deriving
essentially
spinners can be defined without choosing
a metric that
is new i don't think that any critic any
anonymous
pseudonymous or uh i don't know
anonymous
uh person can really criticize that i
mean that's just a fact so
what why why wouldn't phys if if it's
not true
it would be you know almost surprising
but if it is true
um why why haven't physicists noticed
this before and why aren't they making
a bigger deal out of it partially it
might be your fault because you haven't
published this
blame the victim um
who else so what i usually hear about
this is
people say oh you don't understand the
jean pina jumpier bourguignon
told us how to move spinners under
variation of the metric
but he's varying the metric
continuously there's always a metric
present what if there's one metric for a
little while
right which could be the universe before
before god interview are you going to do
a fineman integral
over all variations of the metric i mean
i don't know what kind of pain you're
signing up for but i'd certainly rather
free it look here here's the basic
statement
if we're serious about quantum gravity
we should be very serious about trying
to get fermions that don't
require their bundles to be dependent on
the existence of a metric at all times
and i'm sure that either there's a
brilliant explanation
that i don't understand and i i'm eager
to hear it
or it's a key sign that the community
really dropped the ball remember for
example that the baum aaronov effect
i'm sure that when when aaron often bohm
said hey shouldn't there be an effect of
this uh
zero field strength uh they probably
thought
have i lost my mind i'm sure that yang
and lee
when they proposed that maybe the weak
force was left right
asymmetric probably thought are we going
to be laughed at did we just not
understand what everybody else
understood
physics gets things really spectacularly
wrong
occasionally and i i'm curious to know
if this is one of those moments
yeah i mean you might also say oh
there's 26 dimensions in
heterotic string theory uh that can't be
right no it's only 10
or 11 or five-brained uh membrane theory
um i want to ask another question which
is uh frequently used and criticisms
both
anonymous and anonymous which is that
this doesn't
actually i really don't want to talk
about anonymous trolls with phds
criticizing the theory
and i also don't want to talk about
non-constructive hit
jobs on new theories last time i checked
physics was in a crisis that some people
were admitting to and other people were
sweeping under the rug
okay well you have a crisis wait wait
wait if you have a crisis
for god's sakes open it up we don't need
one more talk
uh from the same crowd of people who
have been keynoting every conference of
note
for the last 30 years who haven't got
the new ideas
let's at least hear crazier weirder
wilder people
and if you guys don't have the guts and
courage to do it from inside the
community hear it from a podcast
okay well this is my podcast and i do
want to respond to these
criticisms because for me uh i don't
find them legitimate
and you can choose to be silent as is
your want no
it's it's rare to to i wish to punish
dysfunctional cowards who um
attempt to snipe pretending to be
helpful
uh you can do better okay i can do
better
uh as well but i do want to say uh that
uh this is maybe
a general comment not for uh
pseudonymous and anonymous people
uh bananamouse uh but but this is a
general uh complaint that i've heard
uh it has to reproduce quantum theory
and i think
forget about that with regard to gu it
could be said about other theories loop
quantum gravity etc
first of all i think gu does produce uh
what we would say is a relativistic
quantum field theory in the dirac
equation
which is manifestly resplendent and
produced and predicted so
i'm not gonna i don't want to hear from
you just yet eric i do want to get your
response
but this notion that a theory of
everything has to subsume
anything i said this uh to our mutual
friend stefan alexander
a professor at brown university and
esteemed cosmologist
and close friend to both eric and myself
uh
i said look at i don't think it's valid
to say that
any theory of everything string theory
or whatever has to predict
every manifestation of physics and this
is where i take issue
and i i make truck with uh professor
kaku
who says things like the one inch long
god equation will predict everything i
don't think that's possible a
i don't think it's useful to think about
the goal of physics is to predict
every phenomenon in physics
because it's an uncautious statement
really what you're trying to say is that
there's stuff that you should be able to
read off from the basic setup of
theory directly and there's stuff that
you should work your ass off in order to
get from the theory
now you know we don't see quarks running
around
free the way you might imagine naively
you would if you were looking at the
hadronic part
of the standard model lagrangian
so you have to work pretty hard i would
imagine in order to find these bound
states that we call protons and neutrons
and try to understand infrared slavery
etcetera etcetera
now that's part of the hazard of saying
i can predict
everything no even computationally you
don't think so
really it's just a question of we should
be able to recover everything that we've
already done
and actually i think that that's pretty
fair
so even there's a dumb way to do it i
think there's a dumb way of doing it
where you try to say
um show me this or then you don't have
anything and
i have to say i encounter a tremendous
amount of that from people who are old
enough to drink
and i it gives me pause as to
who's raising the young
that's not the issue the issue is
they're right
they should be saying look here's what
we know how to do
and you should be looking to recover
what we already know how to do from what
what you're saying and i think that's
actually
fair um there's a question of should you
be able to do everything on day one
should you be able to do it when you've
been cut off for 27 years working
completely on your own
uh under totally weird circumstances
where
every month you feel you get farther and
farther away from the literature and
your brain hasn't spoken this language
in a million years
those are questions that i feel like
it's really sad because they don't
people don't understand what the cost of
isolation is
i do think however that
working in a context with competent
people who aren't constantly trying to
rename everything after themselves
uh there's no question that that's a
reasonable and fair thing if we had a
collegial world
based on a desire to advance our
understanding and i'm happy if
i fail at that with with a collection of
constructive colleagues to say that
that's a black mark against the theory
that's fine
now when i look at the corresponding
shall we say imprecations against ring
theory i would say things like uh
the swampland the multiverse problem
these may be
you know uh issues that cause stillbirth
in
in many people's minds i've talked to
you about paul steinhardt the einstein
professor of natural science at
princeton
he regards the string theory as
essentially bad
for society not just for physics not
just for science but bad for society
because
of the extravagance and the truest sense
of the word in a bad sense of the word
of the of the multiverse and string
landscape now i know you're shaking your
head
um go ahead let me be very clear about
it
we're we're wimping out from what needs
to be said
and it's really important that the
community i think gets it right
i don't think string theory is a problem
strength theory can't harm anyone string
theory doesn't
it's the string theorists when they're
in their triumphalist mode
which are inside that's it's an
insufferable state of being but even
then
you know um i'm sure feynman was
insufferable
and i think murray delmon was
insufferable and
paulie was pretty insufferable we've had
insufferable members of our community
for a very long time and we should not
be getting rid of insufferable people
the problem is what happens when people
become insufferable
and they don't constantly check in with
the unforgiving nature of the universe i
mean paulie predicted the neutrino
uh
he apologized profusely i've done
something which should never be done b
now i ask you though uh should the
should string theory let's just be
neutral to gu for a second
should string theory from string theory
emerge the aharana foam effect
i mean a true theory of everything it
would right
look and if it took a while to recover
certain features of the world that you
in an effective theory i mean look
let's put it this way um if you look
at the marshallian demand in
economic theory should you be able to
predict that from
uh the lagrangian of the universe
no it's in a different strata of the
world
you should be able to predict things
that are within you know the adjacent
strata
of the theory and then you should you
might have to
appeal to some higher effective theory
i look i i want to defend both the
string theorists and
string theory these are incredibly smart
people who found some real structure
and who never knew when to quit when it
came to
trumpeting just how much better string
theory is than everything else even
there they had a point
they were smarter and deeper in general
than everyone else
and they just weren't as good as they
claimed to be and they weren't as
successful as they claimed to be and
what they did succeed at they didn't
want to take credit for
because it was really mathematics done
in physics departments rather than
physics
and so we have a problem that
sociologically nobody wants to say
that the institute for advanced study
has like
the smartest guys around and a lot of
what they do is in physics
in standard terms it's the mathematics
of physics
and that these are uncomfortable truths
just the same way that
it's uncomfortable that we're taking
seriously somebody who's been out of the
field for 27 years
but these are these are end times we're
having end time conversations
and i think that it's it's you know we
don't need to be
mean about it i think it just needs to
be more honest
okay right with that i give some
applause here let's see if we can hear
that
got some applause eric um smattering
that just was the smattering i want to
take a pause
uh for the cause uh and to uh haven't
have a uh a pause to recognize our guest
today as the esteemed dr eric weinstein
who is a seeker
after truth a seeker after my own heart
in the authentic tradition
of the old one uh his namesake
uh albert now they say this is not a
serious podcast
until you break out the puppets now i
know rogan has a supply of
bows and m16s and all sorts of other
things
i don't have any of those accoutrements
i i i only have my sock puppets
and my gelt uh nobel prize but i do want
to say
that this is a special conversation with
eric because
it really fulfills a promise that was
made uh you know
basically a year ago and then again
again about six months ago on this
podcast which is to release
a uh a stunning amount of new technical
details
and you really surpassed that our mutual
friend james altucher
a podcaster extraordinaire he says that
you should never
under promise and over deliver you
should never
under promise and under deliver you
should over promise and
over deliver meaning that if you say
you're going to get it done
in three months and get a million
customers you should get it done in one
month and get 10 million customers or as
one peter thiel said once what do you
think
will require 10 years but could be done
in six months so
what you've done is released a
tremendous amount of technical
information that will be
fully released at some point to the
public but also i want to take
our audience through some of these
delightful animations i put the
i put the link in the chat for now but
i'm going to share my screen right now
hopefully you can see it as well eric
these are now
movies i want you to uh to animate i'll
put you in the lower corner
let's see if i can do that i'll do that
in a second let's see i'll add eric
nope i'll swap these here we go i'm
going to swap eric if you're willing
to swap there we go uh i want to walk us
through which
which one of these uh many videos should
we should we take a look at i was
fascinated by the shiab
but that's just my uh yeah the first
three okay so the first one is called
great great insight and we're gonna do
this for people who are somewhat physics
minded
but who like to complain that none of
this is understandable and by the way
um there are some names associated with
these videos brooke
dallas has been shepherding the project
brendan stone
uh has been incredibly helpful
technically boku
a mysterious uh german man who animates
many of these things
there's a list of people who've
contributed
tim the mirthless swagman from australia
math student down there
so what what they've done is they've
tried to interpret what it is that i'm
saying because i tend
because of learning issues to not think
symbolically wait stop
brian yeah let's blow that up
full screen it is full screen here yeah
okay um that ship
that you're seeing is called curvature
and it has three masts because it has
three irreducible components usually
one mast is called vial curvature one
mast is called traceless richie
curvature
and one mast is called richie scalar
and the first greatest insight
maybe of the 20th century was the way in
which we could feedback the curvature of
the levitrovita connection
into being a co-vector field on the
space of all metrics
and we this is depicted as a boat going
into a bottle that has a rather wide
opening so let's run the
run the animation okay so we've got a
metric the metric has a connection the
connection produces curvature that's
romanian we find that by identities it's
got
three components it tries to go towards
metrics and the vial curvature is
snapped off
afterwards the scalar curvature is
lowered somewhat or adjusted
by scalar curvature over two times g mu
nu
and so symbolically what we've done is
we've said
einstein threw away the vial curvature
readjusted the ricci scalar curvature
and fed
metric information through to the love
echovita connection
through to the riemann curvature tensor
and then played these projection games
to feed it back to the space of metrics
and that particular combination
is perpendicular to the action of the
diffumorphism group on the space of all
metrics
leading to a divergence-free condition
via the
friend the bianchi identity now why
can't we do that and feed this
information
back to the space of connections
rather than the space of metrics because
we would love to link
space-time games with uh
gauge potential game so let's see
whether general relativity engaged
theory have an incompatibility problem
as we try to play the same game we start
off with the riemann curvature tensor
but now the neck is narrower
and what's really going on is is that
this is kind of evocative of trying to
feed it into the space of connections
but the gauge group acts
differently on two different factors
namely
[Music]
if connections are add valued one forms
and curvature
is a an add or lee algebra value 2 form
the problem here is that gauge
transformations
act on the lee algebra component and
don't touch the form
component but einsteinian
projection or contraction or summing
over
gmu new indices is democratic it deals
simultaneously with the form piece and
the lee algebra
piece so if you treat only the lee
algebra piece under a gauge
transformation and you don't touch the
form piece
then contraction followed by gauge
transformation will never be the same
thing
as gauge transformation followed by
contraction
and so that's the puzzle which is if
geometric unity
is really about the idea of trying to
say maybe it's not so much
quantizing gravity maybe it's a fight
between
the different geometry of riemann and
arismond because gauge transformations
are arismanian geometry
but contractions are romanian geometry
so here's a gu approach how do you get
geometric
uh harmony between general relativity
and gauge theory
when you have the ship in a bottle
problem and this is kind of almost a
tight analogy you've got the curvature
tensor
you apply a gauge transformation to two
of the masts
and you pass them through into
add valued d minus one forms and then
you do an inverse
gauge transformation which is exactly
how you do the ship in the bottle trick
by the way brian gave me a wonderful
ship involved thank you very much
raising the mass inside and then you can
potentially if need be
adjust one of the two masts again in
order to get agreement
so in part the the idea is
how do you get harmony
what you need to do is to promote one of
the
um we need to promote the gauge
transformations initially to field
content
in order to make sure that you're
carrying around enough information
effectively
to uh ensure that contraction is
compatible
with uh gauge transformation so
now that is a very tight
idea of how these operators function
inside of the theory
um well this is just for some reason
whenever we talk about gage theories we
don't give people very concrete examples
many of you who are not professionals
will not know how to gauge theories
may i make a recommendation brian yeah
of course
let's go to another animation um which
is something like calc
gauge theories calculus done right yeah
and blow that up
as big as it can be before starting the
animation
okay start the animation
let's imagine that we have a salary that
is constant
in dollar terms over time but somebody
is facing
inflationary pressures on their basket
of goods
now the question is pause please
what we now have is a ten dollar an hour
salary and if we claim that it's
constant
constant means derivative equals zero
yes
but we know that it's not constant
purchasing power
so we have two notions of constancy how
are they related
let's go back to that please yeah
we do a gauge transformation and what
you see pause please
you now see that these little hash lines
are the reference levels that we call a
connection
and we decide that rise over run
should not be measured from a naive
horizontal but should be measured
instead from a custom reference level
represented by the hash marks
now if you let it go a little bit
and then stop it stop
now you see that derivative equals zero
if we measure rise over run above the
hash marks
is a salary that keeps pace with
inflation
and the current 10 an hour is actually a
negative
derivative because the rise over run is
measured beneath those hash lines
that situation is actually an
application of gauge theory to a very
simple problem in economics
completely depicted by stretching the
fibers in the x
y plane and if you look online right now
and say what's a gage
theory you'll be bamboozled by a bunch
of stuff that nobody can understand
unless they're actually insiders
so i think it's very interesting that
again just as it was elementary to ask
the question what what happens to the
fermion medium while we're blinking out
the supposedly quantum metric
why is it that we don't actually explain
to anyone what a gauge transformation
and visualize it and i'm very proud of
our team
for taking this very simple example and
showing
what a gauge field is it's those little
hash lines
effectively those things in higher
dimensions
would be the electromagnetic potential
which becomes the photon under
quantization
and if you're thinking about qed
effectively the
uh the electron is a function and the
photon is a derivative
because what you're specifying is the
levels above which uh you're going to
measure rise over run now you can go
back to the original
floating plane floating
point i just didn't want to take a
second here uh this is brian keating now
speaking
uh so if you look up uh juan maldasena
you will find only one podcast that he's
ever been on
uh and that is the into the impossible
podcast
if you look up uh gage theory and
uh an intuitive way to understand gage
theory something like that
uh you'll come up with this really
brilliant economic analogy
uh that sounds like you know eric has
copied from from juan maldosena
and in fact this came up recently were
people talking about inflation
stabilized items and bitcoin and
and so forth and then um it was very
frustrating to me and i imagine
much more so for eric although he
doesn't have to comment he's too much of
a gentleman
uh this is eric's work uh this gauge uh
gauge theory applied to economic uh
transactions
eric and pia milani yep pia milani uh of
course
uh the beautiful talented uh wife of
eric weinstein eric is known as
the husband of pia milani mostly and uh
and this work was really uh is brilliant
and is deserving of attention in its own
right
independent of the brilliance of it as
an analogy to explain a very complicated
uh subject such as gage theory or a very
simple subject like calculus as eric is
now uh
uh explaining to us i wanted to say that
you don't have to respond if you don't
want to eric i find it very frustrating
when i see oh eric you've got to learn
what mal the saint has said about
i'm like f you uh that's that's very
frustrating to me
that's what that was what was hurtful
because juan
knew that he had gotten this um
he knew about pia milani he
needed to reference her he did reference
her but in a very slight
like minimal way it's a footnote to
version it's a footnote
he knows better the problem that i'm
having problem what i'm having with
it is that the professional community
does not understand
that it has impulses that it hasn't
faced which is that it tends to
brutalize those that it doesn't need to
cite
that it doesn't see just doesn't see
people
and so to have look i'm i'm a huge one
now the saint of fan as are we all
me too but i'm not going to sit around
and i'm
and have people say you what you really
need to do is to listen to juan mao the
cena
uh whose brilliance knows no bounds he
did
something really profound about markets
engaged theory because quite frankly
pia milani deserved to have an entire
career built around it i think it could
easily be the most
deep insight in mathematical economics
of the last 25 to 50 years
and please show me another given that
the marginal revolution originally was
the penetration of differential calculus
into economics
her thesis which is largely joint work
but was not allowed even allowed to to
to be what it was supposed to be um
rebased the field of economics on gage
theory as the correct form of calculus
and
uh what what i'll tell you what i don't
really want to [ __ ] about juan mal the
cena what i would really love to do
is to have juan mao the cena who showed
so much excitement when you know when i
confronted him about this
he says oh you know who that is because
he had no idea who milani was
it would be really great if juan maldena
did this work and i won't say another
word this podcast about it
okay and i will say only one word
because it's my podcast and i can do
whatever the hell i want
uh i had on kamran vapha as you know uh
who wrote a book called puzzles to
unwrap the universe
in which he cites juan maldasena and
i called him on that i said this was
actually original work by pia milani
eric weinstein
and it almost doesn't matter and i find
that very frustrating because the very
same people and you don't have to
respond
please don't respond uh again i'm a
blowhard on my own podcast it's one of
our
prerogatives we get so little of these
things and treats in life
uh but um but i find it very
disingenuous of the community
i love qumran too but to say that uh
well this isn't serious eric you have to
cite this paper
you have to put out a paper about gu
you've only done things on joe rogan
i find that disingenuous um you don't
have to respond
uh let's go on what i will say is this
um when you have gatekeepers
in the form of advisors if you have job
market meetings where people wield
incredible power and they hold
other people's careers in the palm of
their hand
if you use these places to crush people
you have no right to comment after the
fact as to why are these people behaving
bizarrely and strangely
because in essence whether you submit
things to journals and have a
perfectly reasonable relationship with
peer review or whether you find that
peer review is basically a tool to
exclude you
and your insights and your claims from
the world depends in large
measure on who you are where you're
coming from it's
it's human dependent it's not
independent of who submits and how
protected they are and
you know the thing that i want to get
across is that
uh the community is producing
trauma in people and then claiming that
it's paranoia
and you have to recognize that trauma
and paranoia look exactly the same
uh when you can't see what the source of
it is if you want to understand what
happened to this theory
read the physics of wall street by james
weatherall chapter 10 in the epilogue
it's rather clear about the fact that
four gentlemen and one lady tried to
steal a trillion dollars over 10 years
by pretending to fix the cpi because
social security and tax brackets were
indexed
and they came up with one point one
percent um
adjustment that would be needed and then
they broke into two teams to find
exactly out
uh the 1.1 percent that they wanted this
was admitted to by robert gordon
and the most brilliant thesis that
probably came through harvard in terms
of mathematical economics was destroyed
so that daniel patrick moynihan and bob
packwood
could have a back end run around the
third rail of politics which is slashing
benefits and raising taxes using
economists to destroy
funnily enough a bright promising woman
of color from the developing world
uh in all in an essentially all-male
field and
uh these people should pay with their
reputation
okay i want to lighten things up again
uh let's talk about jeffrey epstein no
i'm just kidding
uh i made you laugh come on that's a big
that's a big accomplishment all right
let's look at uh one last video here
let me call up a uh let's go to the
videotape as they say
uh go here i'm gonna go to safari
rastafari nope it's not coming up
oh maybe that's because it already
thinks that we've done it let's see here
all right zoom out you have um
you want to do it observers one down at
the bottom yeah i'm trying to get up the
uh tell me when to stop here well you
can't see it right
um uh let me uh let me get my screen
back
here let me kill that
let me kill what else is going on here
screen share show safari
show primary display secondary display
there we go can you see that yeah
okay so at the bottom i see
uh 5d observers spinner dance
uh which one would you like observers 5d
let's do uh let's do 5d
yeah i think i'll explain
what they're trying to depict it's not
exactly how i would have done it but
keep in mind that these are artists
who've been trying to learn
what this is uh by bypassing
um typical okay pause it
yeah can we get rid of that bottom bar
yeah it's the they need to disable it on
their side but i can kill it off here
and there we go
okay um and can you blow that up
or it's as blown up as it can go uh
let's see here i
think it's fairly blown up all right
yeah imagine that that taurus
and as you see in the lower left corner
of the screen
okay is a two-dimensional
model toy model of space-time
so going around through the center is
like groundhog day you come back
to the same place and it's a repeating
time cycle
and space is simply a circle
now in such a world we would normally
think of quantum
field theory or gravity is taking place
on that object and you'd have
fields you'd have effectively functions
called sections
on that object and what you're seeing
here
is something that's very hard to picture
because it's five dimensional but one
one
trick here is because the torus has a
property called parallelizability
the object on the right is a
depiction of a metric
h point that isn't on one of those two
sheets
is a potential metric at any given point
on the torus
so in other words if a metric is a
symmetric
non-degenerate two tensor if you think
of it as a matrix
it would be of the form x
z z y
and the k non-degenerate means that
x y minus z
squared is not equal to zero so that's
what's cutting out that
variety if you will the zeros of the det
of the determinant
uh would be points given that there are
three degrees of freedom in the metric
and so instead of actually having a
metric
uh space time
gu would say replace the torus
by the entire space in that sort of hour
glassy region so the top region would be
like space
space metrics the bottom right below
that
sort of weird diaphanous scarf
is time time metrics and the weird
middle region which is sort of
around that singularity would be
space-time metrics
every way you can stick that doughnut
into that middle region without touching
one of those two sheets
is a valid space-time metric
and what gu would do is to say don't
only dance on the points of the
two-dimensional torus
again the surface is two-dimensional
even though it seems to be
three-dimensional to naive
uh investigation you should actually
have fields that are dancing on all of
the points of the taurus
and simultaneously all of the points in
that middle region
of the uh we call the diablo diagram
you know to to the right to the right
yep
so every point in that region is in play
and if you map imagine that the stuff in
that weird um
hourglassy region on the far right was
like very warm and on the far left was
very cold
but if you map the torus into the far
left region it would be
it would show up as being cold if you
mapped it into the far right
region you'd see it as being very hot so
every way of mapping the torus
in pulls back different information from
that hour glassy region
and that is in large measure in part one
of the things that may be going on with
the illusion of many worlds is is that
what you're seeing is is that the metric
may be capable of pulling back data
that is dancing on the space of all
metrics as well as the space
of all points on the original manifold x
so in this case you've got two two
degrees of freedom on the torus
you've got three degrees of freedom
around the hourglass
and two plus three equals five now
notice that thing up in the top
left which is a ruler protractor
combination that i just
gave a copy to joe rogan
those two sliders are recalibrations of
what it means to be one unit
and that protractor is a recalibration
of what you're going to define to be 90
degrees
so every way of keeping that bottom arm
in a single horizontal position moving
the top
arm and moving the two sliders that's
one of that's three degrees of freedom
in the space of metrics
so that's a different depiction of the
space of metrics
so the big take home from the
restrictive version of gu that we're
exploring here
is that if you allow fields to dance on
the space of metric
apparatus measurement apparatus that the
kind of the paradoxes of measurements
start to make a lot more sense
you could also potentially try to keep
the metric
classical because we have two spaces we
have a space downstairs x which is just
the taurus
and we have a space upstairs which is
the taurus in this case
cross the hourglass region as long as it
doesn't touch the two sheets
so you've got a five-dimensional
manifold hovering over a two-dimensional
manifold
and fields on the five-dimensional
manifold will be perceived on the
two-dimensional manifold
when you pull them back via a particular
einsteinian space time
as fields on the tangent bundle of what
you will call space time
together with fields on the normal
bundle inside of the five dimensions
so the normal bundle of a
two-dimensional manifold in a
five-dimensional space
is three-dimensional so you're going to
see fields that look like let's say
spinners on two dimensions tensor
spinners on three dimension
if you were in four dimensions make that
taurus in your mind
represent a four dimensional space time
then that diablo region would be a
ten dimensional region of metrics right
because four by
four matrices that are symmetric have
four
squared plus four divided by two used
for different degrees of freedom
in other words you get a ten dimensional
normal bundle
now you'll notice that if you have
ordinary spinners on 14 dimensional
space and you pull them back
via a metric which is a mapping of 4
into 14
it looks like spinners on the 4
dimensional space
tensor spinners on the 10 dimensional
normal bundle
if the normal bundle inherits the
frobenius metric
from x13
and you glue in the trace piece in the
right way
you either well if you glue it in the
wrong way you'd get a 7
3 metric on the normal bundle but if you
glue it in the right way you'd get a 6
4 metric on the normal bundle and 6
4 spin 6 comma 4 is a sort of nasty
non-compact group
so you might want to break to its
maximal compact subgroup like
whitten and barnatan discuss
and the interesting thing about spin six
comma spin four
is that it has different names by low
dimensional isomorphism spin
6 is the same thing as su4
and spin 4 is the same thing as su 2
cross su 2
and spin and su4 across su 2 cross su 2
is the petit salaam theory
you can argue that ordinary spinners on
the induced metric in 14 dimensions
glued in the right way pull back
as petit salaam and i don't know if
anyone's ever discussed the connection
between einstein and petit and salah
no well no i you can't say no
i don't know about i don't know um
that's what i'm saying
people have brought it up but yes have
it has it
i don't know i don't know yeah so the
thing is is that spinners on 14
look like spinners on four tensor
spinners on some version of 10.
yeah and whether you're talking about
spin 10 models su5 models or
su4 cross su 2 cross su 2 which is spin
6
cross spin 4 isn't that exactly what we
see in the standard model
mm-hmm
let me just uh see if i can find this
beautiful quote from him because
he's he definitely um
brought this up and
what i recently did when i had him on my
podcast which we haven't released so if
we go
over to my screen share okay
give me one second
let me do this here we go and
so there we go yep
let me read it a particularly intriguing
feature of
so10 which is really spin 10 or could be
spin 6 comma spin 4 is it spinner
representation
used to house the quarks and leptons in
which the states have a simple
representation in terms of basis states
labeled by a set of plus and minus signs
perhaps this suggests composite
structure now here's the sentence that
just floored me
alternatively one could wonder whether
the occurrence of spinners both in
internal space and in space-time is more
than a coincidence
and then he pulls back immediately these
are just intriguing facts they are not
presently incorporated in any compelling
theoretical framework as far as i know
geometric unity is that compelling
framework
awesome very interesting so
as we uh wrap up i do want to
uh see if there are any
uh any other videos you'd like to show
uh that would help the reader or again
i'm gonna put this in the chat
box so people can peruse it i did put it
in the
uh in the actual youtube box description
so people can find that
at their leisure let me see here i see
what's
well i should say that i um
look let's be honest i said i was going
to release a document
and um clearly we haven't
okay april fool's april fool's uh
the big reveal go to go to geometric
unity.org
geometry and uh
yeah and call that up and then brian why
don't you be the first to put your email
address in
to request uh a copy i wouldn't call it
a paper i'd call it a draft
and one of the things i'm looking to do
is i'm looking to get constructive
feedback from people who want to help me
succeed as opposed to people
who just want to be dicks and take me
down because that's just
to be honest not very interesting to me
and i've had a little taste of that and
i'm not that interested
what i would love is to bring your
positive energy
download it read it recognize that um
more or less i've been cobbling this
together from
a million and one different scraps
and that my ability to talk in this way
has been degrading
for years because i have no one to talk
to i'm not in a department i'm doing
this completely on my own
and i was a little bit frightened to
figure out just how much i've forgotten
so we're still finding scraps of paper
and files on old disks and things like
that
i hope that the notation is getting more
and more standard that there are fewer
errors but there's
clearly uh you know this is basically me
going back to
1983-84
and all the time in between where mostly
i didn't talk about this with anybody
and this has been really
terrifying because you know i'm not a
physicist i don't come from this this
community i
revere the community i don't think the
community's been behaving well recently
i don't love
saying that um but i think the commit
community is in a desperate situation
and
uh let's find out whether i have
anything to say or i'm just blowing hot
air
i'm not afraid of that but you know what
would really be meaningful to me
is for people to bring kindness benefit
of the doubt
hope and recognition that it's pretty
tough to try to do all this on your own
and uh
be constructive and take a look and i
think there are two
two email addresses on the paper uh
in draft form um one for technical
feedback and one for general feedback
yeah so uh
i hope that that there's a lot of food
for thought and i do think that let me
just close this out
i think it's a coherent story i think
it's the first
time i've ever heard a coherent story
about how
a very simple beginning would produce
something that would look like
our world there are things that i would
call predictions in it
that uh talk about what internal quantum
numbers you would expect
to find likely next in terms of uh
there's much more matter there's there's
matter that should be dark there's
matter that might be luminous but not at
the right energy level yet
you would have to in order to compute
with it be able to figure out what
fields have acquired vevs and where we
are in anthropic spaces in some places
but the internal coherence is much
sharper than a few
you know there's still some things that
i'm trying to locate
uh my favorite version of
one is the shiab operator i know how to
produce she have operators in general
but i had a sheet of paper with um
do you remember like paper with feeds
with holes on either side oh yeah loose
leaf
yeah oh feed oh not printer paper
printer paper dot matrix yeah so i
i did uh some calculations in
representation theory that came up with
the projections that i used to use that
i'm looking for and the thing that i
remember is that they've got the
yellow highlighter and um these
perforated holes on either side it i
haven't been able to find it yet so
it's a very long process taking about
37 years of speculation sometimes more
active than others
and trying to put it in one document so
i would really appreciate it if people
wanted to take a gander
through it try to see some of the ideas
and recognize
that if we are going to get off this
planet with its hydrogen bombs and crazy
leaders
and diversify and take some some bets
rockets are not going to do it there is
no real mars robust or
occupy mars strategy and there's one
quote that keeps coming back to me our
home is in the stars or not at all
if we're going to sit here on a hot
crowded planet with thermonuclear
weapons
we maybe we have hundreds of years but
we don't have thousands
and if we're going to get off this
planet and go someplace interesting
um we're going to have to recognize that
we don't have the source code yet in
einstein and it's very limiting
and we're going to have to actually say
what is the source code and if it turns
out that we can find it
we're going to have to be good stewards
and we're not going to do the same thing
that we've been doing by handing the
stuff over to leaders who don't take
seriously
the burdens of um
god-like powers that we the technical
people bestowed so brian thanks for
having me on
and it's a pleasure to interact with
your audience eric it's a pleasure to
have you on the show as always you're
welcome back anytime
i do love the fact that you made this
promise uh
back in uh back in early or late
december
of 2020 that year that
may it soon be forgotten
that's right well you succeeded you
succeeded for sure eric
uh i want to thank you for your
generosity of time and spirit and advice
that you've given to me i hope i can
help to serve you in this wherever this
project may take you it's
now out of your hands it's into the
world and it's going to hopefully sprout
many many delightful new discoveries uh
for the benefit of all mankind as our
friend alfred nobel
so warmly engendered upon the world eric
best of luck congratulations uh we'll do
a part
three next year on this date on this
auspicious date and let it forever be
known
as a day of famine not infamy for years
to come in physics
if we can follow the lead of the
generous the
mercurial the geniarific eric weinstein
thank you so much eric enjoy the day and
we look forward to seeing you on joe
rogan
tomorrow or when will that uh podcast be
out
in the electron layer okay
good night everybody please do subscribe
and like this podcast we have michiokaku
coming up
john mather winner of the 2006 nobel
prize
ideas to the space to make it safe for
new ideas and for creativity
because we do have this one universe as
one life
and it is eminently precious so for now
thanking you all
enjoy the rest of your evening and
thanking you eric here's a musical outro
from our friend miguel tully proprietor
of the yeti tears
podcast spotify and youtube channel
good night everybody
you